despite only appearing on screen a few
times in the original Star Wars trilogy
Boba Fett has become one of the sagas
most iconic characters from his unusual
beginnings to his untimely demise this
is everything you need to know about the
story of Boba Fett during the last days
of the Old Republic a group of cloners
on the planet Kamino created a clone
army supposedly on the orders of the
Jedi High Council to do this they use
the genetic material of a bounty hunter
named Jango Fett
there was one clone however who remained
unaltered at Django's request this
unaltered clone is Boba Fett who was
raised to believe that he is Django's
actual son and that's where this story
begins enter obi-wan Kenobi hello that
when obi-wan arrives on Kamino to
question Jango about his involvement in
the assassination attempt of Padme
Amidala their relationship gets off to a
fairly rocky start obi-wan knows that
Jango is the killer he's been looking
for and Jango realizes he and his son
will need to make a quick getaway it's
at this point that Boba Fett's hatred
for the Jedi Order begins even as a
child he's witnessed their distrust of
his father a man he very clearly looks
up to after deliberating with the Jedi
Council obi-wan Kenobi returns to
apprehend Jango Fett by the time he gets
back however Jango and Bobo are in the
process of making their escape from
Kamino when a fight breaks out between
obi-wan and Jango outside Django's ship
boba is forced to defend his father
against the Jedi the FETs managed to
escape but not before obi-wan is able to
secure a homing device on the hull of
their ship he catches up to the pair
near Geonosis and the battle continues
in an asteroid field thinking they've
outrun obi-wan the FETs take refuge on
the planet along with Count Dooku and
his separatist army when the Jedi
stormed Geonosis to come to Obi Wan's
aid a battle ensues that brings them
face to face with the full force of
Count Dooku's army Boba Fett watches
from the sidelines as his father enters
the fray acting first as duke whose
personal bodyguard and eventually going
head-on against Jedi Master Mace Windu
after a brief fight Windu takes Jango
out with a single swing of his
lightsaber cutting off his head and
leaving boba in orphan boba vows revenge
on mace Windu for his father's death and
vanishes just as the new Grand Army of
the Republic swoops in to save the Jedi
thus beginning an all-out war that would
last for the next three
years it's during this time that boba
fett meets up with several intergalactic
bounty hunters most notable of whom is
Aurra sing a ruthless bounty hunter and
former acquaintance of Django's ora
essentially adopts boba allowing him to
work on her crew while teaching him the
ins and outs of the trade in the Clone
Wars Boba's real introduction to his
father's line of work his rough made all
the more difficult by auras heartless
approach to their business anyone who
crosses her is killed without a second
thought
and although boba sees himself as part
of her inner circle it becomes clear as
time goes on that he's only there to
serve her interests part of Boba Fett's
arrangement with Aurra sing involves her
helping him exact revenge on mace windu
for the death of his father
Boba's first attempt on Mace Windu's
life is the result of an intricate plan
which first involves him posing as a
clone cadet to gain access to the
endurance a republic cruiser on which
the Jedi Master is located boba plants
an explosive device in Windu's quarters
but the assassination attempt fails when
an unlucky clone trooper trips the
device instead at this point boba
decides the best cause of action would
be to take out the ship's reactor boba
then escapes the ship alongside a group
of fellow clone cadets but abandons them
in the middle of space when aura shows
up to rescue him
boba has come pretty far in his bounty
hunter training by now so while he is
reluctant to leave his friends to die he
does so nonetheless after all the life
of a bounty hunter doesn't allow room
for such trivial things as friends not
willing to just let things go after his
first failed attempt boba fett decides
to have another go at mace windu this
time by leaving a sabotage Mandalorian
helmet in the wreckage of the crashed
endurance again his plan fails this time
mace is able to put two and two together
seconds before the device is set to go
off and uses the Force to throw it just
far enough to save Anakin and himself
thinking his plan has succeeded boba
convinces aura saying to return to the
crash site by telling her that Count
Dooku will pay a higher bounty if
they're able to turn over the Jedi's
head he also picks a fight with another
bounty hunter and asserts himself as the
guy who's been taking all the risks
unfortunately they're stopped by r2d2
who's able to pull mace windu and a
young Anakin Skywalker to safety before
boba and the gang can finish what they
started at this point boba fett knows
he's failed twice to kill the man
responsible for his father's murder and
it's starting to get to him or a
saying decides the best thing to do is
to murder one of the clone hostages
they've been saving for Count Dooku and
send the footage to the Jedi Council
along with the demand that mace windu
face boba in response the Jedi dispatch
a couple of their own to track down the
bounty hunters on florrum boba Ora and
the rest of the crew are confronted by
platoon and Anakin Skywalker's Padawan
apprentice ahsoka tano
after a quick skirmish boba does what he
does best and sets another bomb off but
the blast only allows for aura to escape
essentially abandoning the kid in order
to save herself realizing he's been
deserted by the only person he had left
in the universe
boba comes to understand that maybe
vengeance isn't the best life path he's
quickly arrested and although he admits
his wrongdoing he refuses to ever
forgive mace windu fast forward a couple
of years and Boba Fett is the head of
his own bounty hunter outfit the Bounty
Hunter bosque convinces the Sith
assassin Asajj Ventress to join them on
an upcoming assignment and she does but
she and boba immediately butt heads
because she thinks he's too young and
inexperienced to actually know what he's
doing over the course of their
assignment the other bounty hunters
become lost and boba and Ventress wind
up fighting over what to do with the
actual bounty once it's been acquired
boba by this time still has no idea how
to best someone with force abilities
so he's overpowered and left to spend
the following years wallowing in his
hatred as the Galactic Empire comes into
power boba fett and his crew become one
of the most sought after bounty hunting
outfits in the galaxy he develops a
reputation for ruthlessness and is
generally not known to bring in live
bounties no disintegrations it's at this
point in time that boba has taken up
wearing the same sort of Mandalorian
armor that his father used to wear
albeit with some minor changes instead
of the silver and blue that Jango wore
Boba's armor is green and gold and while
it's been beat up in battle worn over
the years it's also got a working rocket
pack and flamethrower
he's also managed to reacquire his
father ship the slave 1 making him a
near identical copy of his clone war era
father or a clone if you will one of
Boba Fett's top clients is Jabba the
Hutt a gangster with deep ties to both
the political and criminal world when
Han Solo's debts to Jabba become too
much for the crime boss to excuse he
hires boba to retrieve him
han tries to make an escape in a cluster
of space trash but
successfully tracks him to bespin then
after setting a trap for the rebels in
Cloud City boba does what any shrewd
businessman would and takes in to
bounties for the price of one he turns
the rebels over to Darth Vader but does
so under the condition that he can take
Han as prisoner to be delivered to Java
this of course means freezing him in
carbonite first therefore creating one
of the most macabre wall hangings in the
galaxy but Boba Fett's success is
short-lived in Return of the Jedi the
bounty hunter seems to be enjoying his
victory over Han Solo hanging out with
Jabba the Hutt and his palace on
Tatooine but things start to go awry
when Luke Skywalker attempts to stage a
rescue and seemingly fails getting
himself sentenced to die and job as a
great pit of Carkoon on the way to his
execution at the Sarlacc pit Luke breaks
free and boba steps in to try and thwart
the rebels escape call it dumb luck or
an uneven match but in spite of Boba's
high-tech gear fighting prowess a freak
accident puts an end to his life and his
infamous career let's face it it's not
an impressive end for the legendary
bounty hunter in the original Star Wars
Expanded Universe Boba Fett survived his
tumble into the pit and went on to have
a long and illustrious career but its
removal from Cannon has left many
wondering what exactly happened to the
famed bounty hunter as it turns out he
may have actually made it out alive
after all the 2015 novel star wars
aftermath shed some light on what
happened to boba in the time following
the events of Return of the Jedi when
two travelers come across a Jawa
sandcrawler on Tatooine they discover
the wreckage of a sail barge reminiscent
of the one used by Jabba the Hutt their
other big discovery damaged Mandalorian
armor that looks as though it's been in
contact with acid since Tsar lacs use
acid to digest their food and it can
take up to 1,000 years to do it the
amount of time between when Fett fell
into the pit and when the Mandalorian
armor was found suggests that he was
able to make it out before being
completely consumed by the creature when
Boba Fett's standalone film was scrapped
in favor of Disney Plus series the
Mandalorian fans were left wondering if
the original bounty hunter would ever
see the light of Star Wars Canon again
but the show may have given an answer to
that question in its fifth episode the
gunslinger when the Mandalorian makes an
emergency landing on Tatooine he takes a
job helping to locate an assassin named
fennec SH and fast-forward to the end of
the episode
and is dead and mando has hit the
interstellar road with baby Yoda stop
touching things
but in the episodes final moments a
mysterious stranger approaches the body
a stranger accompanied by the sound of
Spurs boba fett fans were quick to point
out the possibility that this new bounty
hunter could in fact be their beloved
lost Mandalorian mostly because boba was
accompanied by the same sound effect in
the original trilogy the fact that the
cameos backdrop took place on the same
planet
boba supposedly died on also felt a
little too much to be mere coincidence
others meanwhile argued that it couldn't
have been Fett citing among other things
the length of the strangers cape
regardless the mysterious strangers
appearance certainly seems to have
opened the door to a future run in
between Boba Fett and the Mandalorian
whether that actually takes place
however is yet to be seen check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]